[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in my blood
[Music]
broke my trust and skip town well [ __ ]
him
only thing i care about now is the data
he left in nc
specifically what's on his comp check
the attachment
you'll see what to do
uh
[Music]
so
yes
i'll skin you and make a purse for my
wife
hey [ __ ]
[ __ ]
texas
so
no don't worry
never ever
all right
so
uh feet
your feet right you find the data bank
right to the chase huh well you'll never
guess where i found it
scav hunt
sandra you there yeah
it's just that well ever since they told
me what happened
i just can't stop seeing them i figured
they must have had it
but you know it's not like i was gonna
go looking for it myself
after i keep telling myself it's over
the ones who took me are gone
listen you've got trauma team platinum
you couldn't be in better hands
i'm sure they already fixed the sig
jammer export
true but who knows what the scavs will
cook up next time
anyway that's all in the past now got
bigger fish to fry you want to talk
about it
it's nothing just bring the data back to
my apartment
sending you the address now thanks
ugh
oh
[Music]
we lost everything
[Applause]
we had to pay the price
yeah we lost everything
we have to play the prize
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
sandra it's me v i got your data back
sandra you in there are you alone
did anyone follow you what does it look
like
come on don't like leaving the door open
still worried about the scavs my um
friend
told me your memory be scraped clean the
scavengers
no i'm worried about um no it doesn't
matter
you bring the data bank tax on
unaffiliated persons has not exceeded
the average
if it's not the scavs you're worried
about then who look i didn't pay you to
come here and ask me personal questions
nice put hey you mentioned it besides i
saved your life
that isn't worth anything it was worth
whatever you
got paid don't pretend i wasn't just
another small-time job for you
now did you bring the data back
here don't worry it's completely intact
when someone tells me not to worry it
usually means they're hiding something
you wouldn't happen to have seen what's
inside would you
i'm a professional i have a reputation
to uphold
hmm good then here you go for your
professionalism i threw in a little
extra for minding your own data
thanks be seeing you